hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a quick gameplay preview of monster
fever it's a new game by King that is
out in soft launch right now and it used
to be a pretty popular title on royal
games so I played it before a couple
things I mentioned because it's a time
game so I can't really talk as much
while I play it's a little different it
seems like as far as I can tell it it
doesn't have levels like in the sense of
where you have to beat the way up to you
know complete the objective or whatever
there are timed trials and you keep
playing until you get enough XPS to move
on to the next so you can see here it
says I'm on level 4 I had to play 1 2 &
3 over and over until I got enough XP
collected to get into number four so
that's if that might change some i'm not
sure but right now that's how it is and
this is quarter Roy this is one of the
characters that you start out with you
can see there's some other ones here
there's a little description of him but
there's different ones here that some of
them you can buy with coins some of them
you could buy with these gems I haven't
bought any yet I haven't needed to
because I was just figuring it out but
basically the way the game works is we
have a timed board we have to collect
like light color it's like a collapsing
style like Diamond digger or pet rescue
if they click on ones under the same
colors that are touching each other and
we want to make matches of three or more
and ones that are four or more or five
or more give us these little disco guys
that you'll see and when we bring those
down to the bottom that will start a
monster fever hopefully if we're lucky
so I'm going to play at one time and try
to explain if I can but like I said it's
kind of fast so it's it's a little bit
hard to talk and think at the same time
so there comes our first little disco
guy if we can get them all in the same
area that's good but it's not it's not
it's not
totally necessary we do want to get them
around those areas and then once we get
one all the way to the bottom you'll see
the the Cascade start so I can just go
ahead and click them too and that will
start the disco you can see how they how
it fills up the meter there and if you
get enough to fall to the bottom in the
Cascade then you get the you'll start
the actual monster fever and we did so
now we get more points and corduroy does
his little dance there so now we have 17
seconds left so I'm going to try to get
another one if I can sometimes sometimes
it can be difficult just depends on how
they lay out we actually don't need to
rush to end before because they'll still
drop down at the end when the clock runs
out
so there you can see our game 28,000 out
of 50 so how to keep playing this level
and eventually I'll get to move on so
it's it's neat it's kind of a different
game I'm not a big fan of time games or
timed levels but you know it could be
nice for when you're sitting around and
you want to just see if you can improve
your score we'll see if it changes you
never know but if it does we'll make a
new video and explain some of the other
features you can see here I don't know
how these currencies work I know that
you get a thousand of the gems when you
first get it and you can buy characters
with that not sure which is more
valuable you know how sometimes golden
coins one is like the paid currency and
was not I'm not really sure about that
yet and what else is here so they said
there's a bunch of different characters
here for different prices and I guess
that'll be something to check out later
some of the if you can buy right off the
bat so I hope you liked this video
checking it out one of the really cool
things that I liked about it on royal
games with some music so I'm going to
turn that back on real real quick here
so you can hear it on the outro but like
the video subscribe to our channel so
you can get more new videos when they
come out and let us know what you think
about monster fever thanks
you